[Music]
happy deathday to you has arrived on our
screens just in time for Valentine's Day
and similar to the first film there's a
lot to unpack from it if you haven't
watched my recap of the original then
make sure you go and check it out now
just to get you fully up to speed with
the franchise as there are some things
that link together throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about happy deathday to
you so there will be heavy spoilers this
film is definitely worth keeping some
surprises for so if you don't want to
know anything then I highly suggest that
you turn off now but for everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to happy deathday to you picks up
with our protagonist from the first film
tree who is just salt her own murder
after discovering that it was her close
friend Laurie at the end of the first
film whilst things seem like they're
finally fixed this all goes to hell when
Ryan causes roommate is killed by the
baby-faced mascot from the first film
Ryan starts off his own time loop
however unlike tree in the original she
in car and know what he's going through
so they're able to help they manage to
apparently trap the killer that night
and finally unmask him to discover that
underneath is well another Ryan we
discovered that Ryan has been working on
a time machine and that the future Ryan
traveled back in time to stop him from
ever turning it on staying that doing so
would have devastating consequences
unfortunately it gets turned on and
everything goes black before tree is
transported to the morning of her
birthday which is where the original
film started off confusing right well
things don't get any easier when tree
goes to once again participate in the
perfect day to break the loop and she
discovers that not everything is as it
seems
Carter is dating Danielle Laurie isn't
trying to murder a tree and trees mother
is somehow alive obviously fans of the
first film will know that this was a big
plot point that had previously driven a
wedge between her and her father and it
gets even crazier as things go on tree
obviously wants to live in a timeline
mother exists so she teams up with Ryan
to stop the time loop and to help her
remain in this universe unfortunately
the time machine is broken and fixing it
is extremely complex so through several
suicides tree tries to figure out which
method will correctly allow it to be
re-enabled however after a discussion
with her mother tree realizes that this
ideal life may not be for her and urges
her to go back to make things work with
Carter just before Ryan is about to fix
the machine
the Dean breaks in and stops the
experiment but the group managed to get
it back and attempt to fix it which
gives them some downtime in this tree
goes to save Laurie who in this timeline
has been killed by the college professor
that they were both sleeping with in the
first film in this timeline he turns out
to be the big bad and after being
convinced by his wife who caught him and
Laurie having an affair has decided to
kill her fans of the first film will
remember that he was kind of a jerk so
it's great to see him put back into the
role of a villain for this film
anyway after managing to stop him a tree
returns to the machine and she's able to
return home where everything is fixed
the film doesn't stop there though
uncle' sets up a sequel when some time
later the machine is used on Danielle
with the same characters involved it
would be great to see how she learns to
grow as a person in the same way they're
treated in the first film but whether
this will actually happen is another
thing obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on happy death day to you and
if you saw the ending coming or not make
sure you leave your review of the film
in the comments below and if you enjoy
this video then please like it and make
sure you check out my recap on the first
movie which will be linked at the end
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you